j'ai à peu près une cinquantaine de
patients et donc ces enfants là je ne
peux plus les recevoir parce que je ne
veux pas me faire vacciner il n'y a plus
d'enfants qui viennent me voir pour être
rééduqués tout est rangé la dans les
étagères on attend de pouvoir exercer à
nouveau
[Musique]
on a pu au fait faire la télé
orthophonie pendant le premier
confinement et donc moi je me suis mise
tout de suite pour justement bien suivre
mes patients qui n'est pas d'arrêt dans
leur éducation et et là en fait on n'a
pas le choix on est obligé d'arrêter
notre activité ce que je trouve vraiment
aberrant puisque je ne fais rien risquer
à mes patients
[Musique]
il ya déjà une liste d'attenté à chaque
fois très important pour avoir un rendez
vous chez l'orthophoniste ça va de
parement à deux ans et donc ça va
vraiment créer une tension pour pour nos
collègues et puis pour pour tous les
parents pour tous les enfants qui
attendent une rééducation déjà depuis
depuis longtemps
[Musique]
j'avais déjà fait une formation pour
être praticienne en psychothérapie de
couples sont que peut-être avec du de
l'accompagnement familiale de
l'accompagnement scolaire et pourquoi
pas faire des petits ateliers de langues
à des ateliers d'écriture de lecture
pour continuer dans l'aide aux enfants
[Musique]